the real story behind Taylor Swift
surprise Tonight Show performance plus
the BTS mania as the group lands in Los
Angeles hello you guys I missed you I
hope you enjoyed these special New York
episodes but we are back on the daily
grind and our set I've missed this place
in fact just this morning I was at LAX
airport to welcome global pop sensations
BTS who just got to LA ahead of their
American Music Awards performance more
on that craziness in just a few but I'm
kicking things off with a Taylor Swift
who made a last-second surprise at the
Tonight Show it was all part of a
welcome back for Jimmy Fallon who just
lost his mother Gloria when we were
little my mom would walk us to the store
and hear my sister if she would hold
hands and she would squeeze my hand
three times and say I love you and that
would squeeze back I love you too
and last week I was in the hospital and
I didn't I grabbed an tight squeeze I
love you I just knew we're in trouble
yeah Jimmy gave such a beautiful tribute
to his mother and the moment was made
even more poignant by the lyrics to
Taylor's song New Year's Day which he
performed just for Jimmy squeezing the
hand three times in the back of the taxi
I can tell it's gonna be long wrong
I'll be there view the toast to the town
back
but if you strike out and you're calling
hold on
to the memories they
hold on to the memories they
now according to Tonight Show producer
Mike disenzo at that point
Jimmy was at his desk dabbing his eyes
with the tissue quote we all lost him it
was a beautiful coincidence in a
beautiful performance
he also said Taylor was not scheduled to
be on the show but they asked her on a
complete whim and she said yes without
hesitation adding that she did something
beautiful for Jimmy and the show and of
course our thoughts go out to Jimmy and
his family as well but switching gears
to an American Idol alum who was
starting the family of her own
et has learned that Jordin Sparks
secretly said I do to her boyfriend Dana
Isaiah this summer forget this
she is also pregnant the two are
expecting their first child due next
spring her up tells et she is
deliriously happy Jordan and Dana eloped
in Hawaii back in July were the couple
exchanged vows surrounded by a small
group of friends just a month later she
found out she was expecting well
Congrats to the growing family and
finally hashtag welcome to us BTS is
trending worldwide and that's because
the kpop boy band turned crossover pop
phenomenon have touched down in Los
Angeles
that's right fans not only showered them
with love
they just about lost it and I was there
for all the fandemonium
[Music]
it was BTS mania outside of LAX this
morning fans lined up all morning long
just to catch a glimpse of the global
pop sensations
[Applause]
why do you love BTS so much like what so
great about Emily the gun this far
how excited are you guys to see them
today I just stayed up all night and it
was crazy we all stayed up people are
hyped I love you guys so much I'm still
proud of you guys - love you BTS insane
right the boys are in town for a major
performance at this weekend American
Music Awards while they're here they're
also gonna plan to hit Jay Jimmy Kimmel
Live LN and The Late Late Show with
James Corden oh and also the daily Denny
that's right if me plus BTS behind the
scenes at their AMA rehearsal I sit down
with them tomorrow so head over to the
community tab and leave your questions
for the boys there until then make sure
you guys are subscribed to our Channel
and are getting these notifications
because it is BTS week and you don't
want to miss out cannot wait
[Music]